il ya tellement de ces squeeze
aujourd'hui on se retrouve patrick
albérola simulator ce que vous me l'avez
demandé en masse il ya une nouvelle
version du jeu qui vient de sortir
aujourd'hui à midi ça c'était la fois
inutile c'est parti vous allez voilà
quelques nouveautés qui sont assez cool
je regarde un peu les patchs de mise à
jour à l'aube en cours s'est dit par
battant ya des mecs aussi tiendrait pas
de filière bois le bref ces classes si
je suis quelqu'un je suis carrément gris
et ce quoi faire ce qu'on va aller
directement en cours
ah ouais ok maintenant elle a carrément
une prof sans déconner en fait les
filles elles ont un caractère ou si je
te quelqu'un devant elles vont essayer
de sortir de l'école
mais par contre les mecs comme eux là
ils vont se mettre à courir pour aller à
avertir la prof c'est ce que j'ai lu et
du coup je me dis ctions but la prof on
est tranquille et qu'on cloisons grand
plus la sortie de l'école au mollet a
tôt fait carrément une prise d'otage
quoi bon moment au nom de soumission
quoi on a du coup je suis choqué c'est
ça ex balzar pokémon leur prof est
totalement intouchable quoi je crois
qu'il faut améliorer ça pour ensuite
voir créer de fausses lettres de sud
assez fourbe à la salle heures du doj
est alors née sur le toit et attendez on
va pouvoir espionner deux personnes pour
découvrir le point fait d'un élève et
pas des gens là qui parle en cachette je
peux écouter leurs conversations ni vu
ni connu ou pas c'est dans la ronde
ni vu ni côtes de sendaï est en fait
maintenant s'il me voit logiquement ils
peuvent trouver xulu voilà exactement
comme ça qu'est ce que t'as pas du coup
j'arrive espionné personne la [ __ ] bon
je m'arrête
logiquement ici à gauche et une
infirmerie une seringue un
tranquillisant si on peut faire un truc
de fou lors je suis moi viens avec moi
mag revient avec moi je te remets dans
un déjà eu lieu entre pour un peu
glauque quoi bien que moi là dedans là
je ferme ça délicatement et soudainement
jeu blanc pousse elle dans où elle est
morte
je vais bien couture elle peut pas être
partout mais un coup de seringue il faut
que jacques acheter une boîte la mort va
la mettre dedans rentrer dans cette
boîte [ __ ] non je peux aller en cours
j'ai raté l'heure je veux venir
déjà vous étudiez pas vous êtes tous
debout contre le mur quoi attend des
emmerdes
j'ai du sang sur moi au nom richesse du
sang sur moi mais j'ai tranquillité ya
du sang qui gicle c'est quoi ce bordel
père brocade battant mais non et à quoi
il s'est au fait d'ailleurs jamais
checker dans cette chambre iia d'eht agn
les photos que j'ai pris ça fait
vachement voyeur quoi là y'a quoi on
peut changer un peu cherche sa culotte
non mais please nani tu porte encore des
culottes avec des animaux dessus à ton
âge
oui il alors à lomé sas parfait ah c'est
ça sa table de nuit une brosse à dents
qu'elle a volé de la maison de seine
brosser les dents avec ça c'est quelque
chose d'incroyable mais [ __ ] c'est un
bandage que sam pas perdu un peu de son
délicieux sang et de sueur lalao non
mais ça suffit quad mikit hausse est
chiante bordel à ok il sera ajouté plein
de décaissement quoi les choix entre une
biscotte un grille-pain un slip sur la
tête à cette paille dans fois pas comme
ça ces partis faire moins attentivement
cette porte là c'est peut-être
voilà vous ferez pas de cette école au
[ __ ] il peut aborder la tournée des
cdg plus qu'à lâcher ce couteau pour
vite que j'aille me changer ensuite on
est tranquille personne n'est au courant
c'était très discret ya des morts
partout de l'esprit que ça me pailler
moi mais c'est sam bail au my god
est ce que c'est un corps mort non non
qu'il a vu qu'il a vu [ __ ] je vais le
défoncer lui l'eau que je vois tu je
vais le défoncer mais non mais c'est des
petits bugs [ __ ] faut bien en cours je
peux pas aller en cours
mais non non je suis dans une frénésie
meurtrière du coup je peux pas étudié
rôles chez lipp amortir les progiciels
mais c'est sympa j'aime pas évident
je t'aime commenté envers cette porte je
suis dégoûté de tentative de kidnapping
d'une fille là bas là quand je
tranquillise quelqu'un ça marche pas ça
là tu carrément à mais peut-être pas
s'il faut qu'on est meilleurs
compétences en biologie on retombe dans
cette [ __ ] de pièces bras et la
normale va dormir n'y a pas de sens
c'est bon j'ai aussi passé jugeait pas
les compétences en biologie en fait
complètement con et l'a logiquement au
regard des je la mets dans en fait tu
vois tu je retourne étudier ce qui
connaît voilà c'est la fin des cours
chacun rentre chez soi tout le monde est
heureux
l'inde et la chine a quitté l'école est
retournée chez elle est attendu qu'il
soit minuit caché dans l'ombre elle a pu
traverser l'école et s'introduire dans
le gymnase viande à l'achat retourne à
voir la boîte dans laquelle se trouvait
sa victime inconsciente elle a poussé la
boîte jusqu'à sa maison prétendant que
c'était une jeune musicienne de retour
d'un show dans des régions a ramené la
boîte dans sa cave et à attacher sa
victime et donc là si on va dans le bes
met logiquement tempête incroyable et du
coup mes parents ont par ailleurs fait
encore puisque c'est pas du tout la
version finale du jeu c'est ça bah
écoute et on retourne en cours et
j'aimerais bien faire le deuxième truc
là [ __ ] faire genre que quelqu'un
s'est suicidé mais c'est dur ça un jeu
il ya plusieurs modes si j'appuie sur
est assez l'attaqué dite embrassait
magnifique
dq par tous âges plus parler quand même
et si je manque de me suivre attendait
dans le titre va me suivre ou pas j'ai
appris moi the titans bordel c'est le
rêve de toute une vie
et s'il peut venir avec moi là dedans le
titan elle s'en va et c'est elle qui n'a
pas le temps la même année que la jonque
toile sur le toit des titans comme ça
qui font une sorte de deux de ses ex
parti un peu chelou quoi ont bien du
mérite en accéléré au montage s'est
porté sur le tour mais bordel j'avais
pas produit une pompe
regardez comme c'est quelqu'un passe il
décède là il est broyé sociaux on sait
leur de tuer toutes mes concurrentes et
séduire s'aiment pas je prépare déjà le
saut et le ballet os os on est pas mal
déjà là allez salut
ça c'est fait j'active l'incinérateur et
j'ai plus qu'à tout [ __ ] de nettoyer
ça c'est la partie vraiment amusant du
jeu que j'adore ses rangs palpitant
plein d'émotions mais bordel de merde je
veux juste des taux el sol pvc est pas
juste là mais tu fais quoi là bas les
encours sackboy et tu dis moi je vais
d'un garçon qui étudie un qui fera des
grandes études et qu'on aura beau métier
je suis en mode total schizophrénie et
si elle me voyait là me dire quoi
l'homme punir qu'est-ce qu'il va pas à
contrôler thouars mais j'ai rien fait
j'ai jeu mais j'ai rien fait je
tremblais juste un peu je peux avoir
froid quoi mais c'est scandaleux
[ __ ] mais j'ai abandonne saint pie ix
doigt dans le cul intérêts partie des
gangsters viril ça et voyager ans et 10
ans fin de cette seconde vidéo sur
gardien relais simulator j'espère si
vous appelez seca n'existe pas mais les
vidéos comme d'habitude c'est à sucre
parce qu en fait y'a pas de tendre vote
externe à quelques unes qui sont
vraiment bien mais on enfile ton vite
fait finalement il ya une mise à jour du
jeu toutes les deux semaines donc on en
refera une d'ici un mois ou un mois et
demi qu'on aura encore plus de
nouveautés
on s'entend très vite dans une prochaine
vidéo merci d'avoir gardé de chanter mon
fils